It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. One of our producers, Nancy Updike, remembers the first time that she met Kirk Johnson.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们的制作人南希·厄普代克，还记得她第一次见到柯克·约翰逊的情景。
It was 2007. And he told me about a crazy plan that he was considering.
那是2007年。他告诉我一个他正在考虑的疯狂计划。
What was the plan?
是什么计划？
The plan involved Iraqi refugees. At the time, it was a brand new, very raw issue. These were Iraqis who had worked for the US during the Iraq War, interpreting or doing other jobs.
这个计划涉及伊拉克难民。当时，这是一个全新的、非常棘手的问题。这些人是曾经在伊拉克战争期间为美国工作过的伊拉克人，担任翻译或其他工作。
And as the war got worse, they were being targeted for having worked with the US. People were being killed. They were being tortured, kidnapped. A lot went into hiding or went on the run.
随着战争恶化，他们因为曾与美国合作而成为被攻击的目标。有人被杀，被绑架，遭到酷刑。许多人被迫躲藏或逃亡。
And so what was he thinking about doing to deal with this?
那么他当时打算怎么解决这个问题呢？
So the plan he was mulling was, OK, he was going to gather a small group of these Iraqis who'd worked with the US-- around 50-- and somehow get them to Jamaica, somewhere in the Caribbean, at which point he would charter a high-speed boat and race them over to the United States, hoping to outrun the Coast Guard so that he could get them onto American soil where they could claim asylum.
他考虑的计划是：聚集一小群曾为美国工作的伊拉克人——大约50人——设法把他们送到牙买加或加勒比海地区的某个地方，然后他会租一艘高速快艇，带他们冲向美国，希望能在海岸警卫队追上之前，让他们踏上美国领土，从而申请庇护。
Wow.
哇。
That's what I said. That's exactly what I said. Wow.
我当时也是这么说的。我说的就是这个。哇。
So who is Kirk Johnson? Well, he had worked in Iraq with USAID, the agency that gives out America's foreign aid. He spoke Arabic. And by 2007, when Nancy met him, he was still just this guy in his mid-20s, but he had kind of become the public face of this issue-- of Iraqis who had worked with the US forces and were now in danger because of it and had to get out of the country.
那么柯克·约翰逊是谁？嗯，他曾在伊拉克为美国国际开发署（USAID）工作，这是负责发放美国对外援助的机构。他会说阿拉伯语。到2007年南希遇见他时，他不过是个二十多岁的小伙子，但他已经成为这个议题的公众面孔——即那些曾与美军合作、因而在危险境地中必须离开祖国的伊拉克人的代言人。
He was writing about this. He was appearing on TV. He was talking to people in Congress. He set up a nonprofit organization to help these Iraqis.
他为此撰写文章，在电视上露面，与国会议员交谈。他还成立了一个非营利组织来帮助这些伊拉克人。
And Nancy says that when he ran this proposal by her in 2007, she thought to herself, OK, well, here is just somebody who is up against a problem that is so big and intractable, I guess he's mulling over some crazy schemes.
南希说，当他在2007年向她提出这个建议时，她心想，好吧，这只是一个面对如此巨大且棘手问题的人，所以他才想出一些疯狂的方案。
But that's not even what was going on. I talked to him a few weeks ago and found out that that wasn't even his idea. He didn't come up with that.
但这甚至都不是当时真实的情况。几周前我和他谈过，发现那根本不是他的主意。他没想出那个点子。
He told me that this boat chartering, outrunning the Coast Guard scheme had actually been suggested to him by someone pretty high up in the government's refugee resettlement bureaucracy.
他告诉我，这个租船、甩掉海岸警卫队的计划，其实是政府难民安置官僚机构里的一位高层建议他的。
Wow.
哇。
Right. Another wow. Kirk had met with him to ask for help-- regular, above board, inside the bounds of the law help. And the man had told him, in all seriousness, I can't help you from my lofty position. But I've done some research into maritime law. And here's what I think you should do.
没错，又是“哇”。柯克曾会见那个人寻求帮助——寻求正规的、公开的、法律范围内的帮助。那个人很严肃地对他说：“我无法以我目前的高位提供帮助。但我研究过海事法，这是我认为你应该做的。”
And in the years since then, it's been so hard to get these Iraqis who worked with the US to safety that Kirk has thought back on that conversation many, many times, he says. This is Kirk talking about this.
从那以后的几年里，想要保障这些曾为美方工作的伊拉克人的安全变得如此困难，以至于柯克说他无数次回想起那次谈话。这是柯克在谈论这件事。
And as depressing as it was that this was his recommended strategy, I actually still think he's right. And I sometimes wonder, if I had done the boat thing, maybe this issue would have been solved a long time ago.
尽管这个建议让人沮丧，但我真的觉得他说得有道理。我有时在想，如果我当时真的实施了那个“船只计划”，或许这个问题早就解决了。
Wait. Nancy, didn't we solve this problem? Am I remembering wrong? Didn't they pass a law or something that was going to allow exactly these people into the country, people who had worked with US forces in Iraq and their lives were in danger?
等等。南希，我们不是解决了这个问题吗？是我记错了吗？他们不是通过了一项法律或者类似的规定，允许这些人进入美国吗——那些曾为美军工作且生命受到威胁的伊拉克人？
Yeah, more than one law. And I think a lot of people, when they hear about this, have the same reaction. Didn't we fix this? And this issue-- what to do with these Iraqis-- is this zombie problem. It has seemingly been dealt with over and over only to rise again and keep staggering forward.
是的，不止一项法律。我想很多人听到这个时，反应是一样的。我们不是解决了这个问题吗？而这个问题——如何安置这些伊拉克人——成了一个“僵尸问题”。它似乎被反复处理过，却又一次次死灰复燃，继续艰难前行。
We've passed laws starting in 2008. It's not a partisan issue. Republicans and Democrats came together to create a special track for these Iraqis in the visa process to speed them through. But the problem is still not fixed. There are still thousands of Iraqis who worked with the US and have applied to come here out of fear for their lives and their families' lives, and they're still just waiting, often for years.
我们从2008年开始通过法律。这不是一个党派议题。共和党人和民主党人齐心协力，在签证流程中为这些伊拉克人设立了特殊通道以加快审批。但问题依然没解决。成千上万曾为美方工作、因担心自己和家人的生命安全而申请来美的伊拉克人，依然在漫长的等待中，常常一等就是几年。
Well, today on our radio program, yes, for once, a national problem where we all agree that we should fix it and how to fix it. And yet, somehow we have not gotten the job done. Kirk Johnson gives us the incredible behind the scenes stories of what has happened to fix this problem, what has not happened, and why. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
好了，今天的电台节目里，我们要讨论的确实是一个罕见的、全国上下都同意应该解决且知道如何解决的问题。然而，不知为何，我们没能完成任务。柯克·约翰逊将带我们了解解决此问题背后的惊人故事——哪些事做了，哪些没做，以及原因。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Kirk himself, I should say, had no special interest originally in refugees or anything like that. He sometimes says that he stumbled into this issue. Nancy Updike tells what happened.
我得说，柯克本人最初对难民之类的事情并无特殊兴趣。他有时说自己是偶然涉足这个领域的。南希·厄普代克讲述了发生的一切。
Kirk's story starts in kind of a weird place-- on a family vacation in the Dominican Republic, his first vacation after his first year in Iraq. And on his first night there, he sleepwalked up to the open window in his hotel room, woke up, and thought he was still in Fallujah.
柯克的故事开始于一个奇怪的地方——他在多米尼加共和国的家庭度假，这是他结束伊拉克第一年工作后的首次度假。在那里的第一晚，他梦游走到酒店房间敞开的窗户前，醒来时以为自己还在费卢杰。
He shouted and ducked. He says there had been a sniper or snipers in Fallujah around that time who killed more than a dozen Marines. And he thought for a second that he was standing in front of an open window in Fallujah with no body armor.
他尖叫着趴下。他说当时费卢杰有狙击手杀害了十几名海军陆战队员。他那一瞬间以为自己正站在费卢杰一扇敞开的窗前，而身上没有防弹衣。
This was early in the war. And it didn't occur to him that he might have PTSD. He thought it was just some bad, weird dream. The next night, he sleepwalked again, right out the second floor window of the hotel, about a 17-foot fall to concrete. He broke both his wrists, his upper jaw, his nose, cracked his skull, needed about 70 stitches in his face.
那是战争早期。他当时没意识到自己可能患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。他以为那只是个糟糕的怪梦。第二晚，他又梦游了，直接从酒店二楼的窗户掉下去，坠落约17英尺后摔在水泥地上。他摔断了双腕、上颚和鼻子，头骨骨裂，脸上缝了大约70针。
The good part is that I-- most of doctors that I've had, when they take in the extent of the injuries, have told me that there's no reason I should be walking.
好消息是，我遇到的大多数医生在看到受伤程度时，都说我不应该还能站着走路。
Is the explanation for you not being more injured that you were asleep and your body was just limp? Or is it just dumb luck--
你能伤得不重，是因为当时你在睡梦中身体放松了吗？还是纯粹是运气好——
Dumb luck.
纯粹是运气好。
--and youth?
——加上年轻？
Yeah. I just think maybe-- I started taking Centrum multivitamins about a year before the accident. And maybe my bones were sufficiently strong. But I just know I lucked out.
是的。我只是觉得或许——我在事故发生前一年左右开始服用Centrum多种维生素。也许我的骨骼足够强健。但我只知道自己运气不错。
You were spared to be in a Centrum commercial later in life?
你大难不死是为了以后能拍Centrum广告吗？
(LAUGHING) Yeah, right.
（笑）是的，说得对。
Kirk's plan was eight weeks' recovery and then right back to Iraq. Instead, he spent the next several months in his hometown in Illinois, getting a series of painful surgeries, fighting with his health insurance company, struggling to do basic things like eat or hold a pen, and running out of money.
柯克的计划是休养八周后直接回伊拉克。结果，他在家乡伊利诺伊州待了几个月，经历了多次痛苦的手术，与医疗保险公司斗争，努力做吃饭或握笔等基本动作，而且钱快花光了。
Kirk's an ambitious guy. His work in Iraq was something he'd been building toward this whole life. He started learning Arabic at 16 years old, got a Fulbright to Cairo at 21, and at 24, was hired by USAID to go to Iraq. All he wanted was to go back, and he couldn't. He had to restart his adult life from scratch.
柯克是个有野心的人。他在伊拉克的工作是他一生都在为此努力的目标。他16岁开始学阿拉伯语，21岁获得富布赖特奖学金前往开罗，24岁被美国国际开发署聘用前往伊拉克。他唯一想做的就是回去，但他做不到了。他不得不从零开始重建自己的成年生活。
I started studying for the law school admissions test. And I really did feel at that point that I was moving on. I was having the nightmares less. I was thinking about Iraq less. I stopped reading the news from Iraq.
我开始复习法学院入学考试。在那一刻我真的觉得我正在向前看。噩梦变少了。我思考伊拉克的时间少了。我不再阅读伊拉克的新闻。
But one day, one of my good Iraqi friends sent an email-- he was one of the highest ranked Iraqis that worked for USAID. I think it was a $130 million program that he was working on. And he opened up his front door and found the severed head of a dog and a death threat note that said that we're going to cut off your heads. I mean, a very clear death threat lobbed into their front yard.
但有一天，我的一位伊拉克好朋友发来邮件——他是为美国国际开发署工作的最高层伊拉克人之一。我想他当时负责的项目价值1.3亿美元。他打开前门，发现了一颗断掉的狗头和一张死亡威胁纸条，上面写着：“我们要割下你们的头。”这显然是一个扔在他前院的明确死亡威胁。
When Kirk got this email, it was the fall of 2006, and he was practically broke and living in his aunt's basement on a futon. So with the email, he felt like, that's terrible, but there's nothing I can do.
当柯克收到这封邮件时，是在2006年秋天，他几乎身无分文，住在阿姨家的地下室里。收到邮件时，他觉得这太可怕了，但他觉得自己无能为力。
It took him a few weeks to realize that maybe there was something he could do. He started writing an op ed, saying, I think our government should help my friend and people like him.
他花了几个星期才意识到也许他能做点什么。他开始写一篇评论文章，说：“我认为我们的政府应该帮助我的朋友和像他这样的人。”
I felt that of course there's some office to give out visas to these people. Of course the government has some program. It's just that my friends haven't heard about yet. And so--
我觉得肯定有一个部门可以给这些人发放签证。政府肯定有某种项目，只是我的朋友们还没听说过。所以——
And neither have I, but I'll do this op ed, and then I'm going to connect the people.
我没听说过，但我会写这篇评论，然后我会把这些人联系起来。
Yeah, somebody will step forward and just fix it. And I think in my mind, it was kind of as simple as, if I could maybe help him get out-- I didn't know anything about how refugee admissions worked. But I thought that maybe if we could get him out into safety, that I would have one positive thing to look at from my year in Iraq rather than a bunch of failed projects and the accident.
是的，肯定有人会站出来解决这个问题。在我的脑海里，想法很简单：如果能帮他脱险，我至少能从那一年在伊拉克的经历中看到一点积极的东西，而不是那一堆失败的项目和那场事故。
Kirk's op ed ran in the Los Angeles Times in mid-December 2006.
柯克的评论文章于2006年12月中旬在《洛杉矶时报》上刊登。
And I remember thinking, OK. Good job, buddy. What a good thing you've done by raising awareness of this situation. And I was getting back to work on the law school stuff, except that I started getting all of these emails from other former colleagues at USAID, former Iraqi colleagues. It was within an hour or so that it was put online. And then by the afternoon, I was getting hundreds of emails from Iraqis that had read the article but who had worked at the State Department or as interpreters for the military.
我记得当时想，好吧，做得好，伙计。你提高了人们对这个情况的关注，真是件好事。我正准备继续回去做法律考试的事，但突然收到了所有其他在国际开发署工作的前同事、伊拉克前同事的邮件。文章上线不到一小时就有了反应。到了下午，我收到了数百封伊拉克人的邮件，他们读了文章，或者曾经在国务院工作，或者曾为军方担任翻译。
So in other words, people you had not worked with directly, but they knew people who knew you or who had read it and it just got forwarded around.
换句话说，那些你没有直接合作过，但他们认识的人认识你，或者是读了文章后转发给他们的人。
Exactly. And they were all telling me their stories and sending me pictures of family members who had been killed, pictures of their bodies where they had been tortured or shot, pictures of the stumps of limbs that had been blown off while they were interpreting for the Marines.
正是如此。他们都在讲述自己的故事，并发给我家人的照片，家人被杀害的照片，他们被酷刑折磨或枪杀后尸体的照片，还有当他们在为海军翻译时被炸断的残肢照片。
And all of a sudden, I was staring into the guts of the refugee crisis. They were grown men and women and heads of families that were telling me that I was their only hope and that they were putting all of their faith in me to help them with their cases. And I was just this unemployed, scar-faced scrub at that point. I was not like, all right--
突然间，我直面了难民危机的残酷真相。这些成年男女和一家之主告诉我，我是他们唯一的希望，他们把所有的信任都寄托在我身上，请求我帮他们处理案件。而当时我只是个失业的、满脸伤疤的无名小卒。我当时的状态并不是那种“好吧——”
You've come to right place.
你找对人了。
--everybody rally behind me kind of thing. There was none of that. It was just like, holy cow, I have just bumbled into something way bigger than I know what to do with. I need to find the real people who I'll just give this stuff to, and they'll just solve it.
——“大家跟随我”之类的。根本没有。当时的感觉只是：天哪，我笨拙地闯入了一个远超出我能力处理范围的事情。我需要找到真正的相关人员，把这些材料交给他们，让他们去解决。
Kirk didn't know it yet, but there wasn't some special process at the time for dealing with most of these Iraqis. All there was was one small program to let in 50 Iraqi or Afghan interpreters a year. That was it, even though there were tens of thousands of Iraqis doing all sorts of jobs for the United States, jobs that were increasingly risky to be seen doing-- office jobs, operating machinery, working as cooks, drivers, and interpreters.
柯克当时还不知道，当时并没有针对这些伊拉克人的特殊处理流程。只有一个小项目，每年允许50名伊拉克或阿富汗翻译进入。仅此而已。尽管有成千上万的伊拉克人从事着美国各种各样的职位，而这些工作——办公室文员、操作机器、担任厨师、司机和翻译——在外界看来正变得越来越危险。
Kirk started putting together a list of names. And his plan was to meet with representatives from the Refugee Bureau in the State Department and give them the list. Just go to the top and solve the problem directly.
柯克开始整理一份名单。他的计划是与国务院难民署的代表会面，把名单交给他们。直接从高层着手解决问题。
But he wanted to keep his request simple. He knew from working in a government bureaucracy himself, USAID, that simple works best. So his first list was just Iraqis he knew from working at USAID. He would just be the USAID guy with a list of USAID names.
但他想让自己的要求保持简单。他曾经在政府机构国际开发署工作，知道简单才最有效。所以他的第一份名单只是他在国际开发署时认识的伊拉克人。他就是那个带着国际开发署名字名单的“国际开发署小伙”。
He spent weeks tracking them all down, not just the ones who had already written to him, and putting information about each one-- who they were, where they were, what job they'd done, what had happened to them-- into an Excel spreadsheet.
他花了数周时间追踪他们所有人，不仅仅是那些已经给他写过信的，并将每个人的信息——他们是谁，在哪里，做过什么工作，发生过什么事——输入到一个Excel表格里。
Next, Kirk gave the list to the State Department Refugee Bureau. But the meeting was short and inconclusive. He wasn't sure when he left what to expect from them in terms of help for the Iraqis on the list.
接下来，柯克把名单交给了国务院难民署。但那次会面很简短，也没得出什么结果。离开时，他并不确定他们在帮助名单上的伊拉克人方面会提供什么。
And then from that meeting, he headed to a second meeting in Washington. And that's where he got a much clearer sense of how at least some people in the government saw what he was doing. He went to the USAID office.
在那次会议之后，他赶往华盛顿的第二场会议。在那里，他对自己所做的事情在政府中被如何看待有了更清晰的了解。他去了国际开发署的办公室。
I decided to pay a visit to USAID, kind of as a courtesy call to just explain what I thought I was doing with the list and also to just have a talk, because one of my former bosses had called me up after the op ed. He was a Bush appointee. And he had angrily said to me that I was dragging the nation back onto the rooftop of Saigon with the op ed.
我决定拜访一下国际开发署，算是一次礼节性拜访，解释我对自己名单的想法，也顺便聊聊，因为我的一位前上司在评论文章发表后打电话给我。他是布什总统任命的官员。他愤怒地对我说，我发表那篇评论是在拖累国家，让大家想起“西贡的屋顶”。
Meaning Kirk's op ed, which hadn't mentioned Vietnam, had reminded his former boss, and maybe others, that the United States had left Vietnamese allies behind at the end of the Vietnam War. No one in the Bush administration wanted the Iraq War to remind anyone of Vietnam, especially at this point in early 2007, when the war was going so badly.
意思是，柯克的文章虽然没提到越南，却让他的前上司和其他人想起美国在越南战争结束时抛弃了越南盟友。布什政府里没有人希望伊拉克战争让人联想到越南，尤其是在2007年初战争进展如此糟糕的时候。
And I walk into this room, and the Bush appointee that I had last seen in Baghdad, the Saigon rooftop dude, he's got a binder in front of him. It's a green binder, and I notice my name is written on the binding of it.
我走进房间，那个我在巴格达最后一次见的布什任命官员——那个说“西贡屋顶”的家伙——他面前有一个文件夹。是一个绿色文件夹，我注意到书脊上写着我的名字。
And he says, Kirk, I don't know if you're aware about this, but you're not actually allowed to be writing about anything as a former-- you can't write about what you saw in Iraq. You can't write about-- as a former US government official, you have a gag order in your contract.
他说：“柯克，我不知道你知不知道，但你其实作为前官员是不被允许写任何东西的——你不能写你在伊拉克看到的东西。作为美国前政府官员，你的合同里有禁言条款。”
And I knew my contract very well. There was no gag order or anything. And so I got annoyed, because I felt like it was an obnoxious way to start off the meeting. But the tone was very--
我非常了解我的合同。根本没有什么禁言条款之类的东西。所以我很生气，因为我觉得这是一个极其令人厌恶的谈话开头。但语气很——
Don't make us hurt you.
别逼我们伤害你。
Yeah. He said, are you going to write anything else about Iraq? And I said, yes. And he goes, about what? And I said, well, I haven't made up my mind yet. And he goes, well, here's what we would prefer is that you submit all future publications to us for clearance first, because we'd hate to see your objectives tanked or torpedoed-- one of those phrases like, bad things might happen.
是的。他说：“你还要写关于伊拉克的其他东西吗？”我说：“是的。”他说：“关于什么？”我说：“嗯，我还没想好。”他说：“好吧，我们希望你今后所有的出版物先提交给我们审查，因为我们不想看到你的目标被挫败或鱼雷击沉——”之类威胁的话，暗示可能会发生坏事。
And I just remember telling him that if you guys want to come after me on this, go for it. But just imagine what that's going to look like, that USAID is going after a former USAID employee for trying to help former USAID employees.
我只记得告诉他，如果你们想在这件事上找我麻烦，那就来吧。但想象一下那会是什么样子——美国国际开发署要去对付一个试图帮助国际开发署前员工的前员工。
That's about where the meeting ended. But the strangest part was what happened afterward.
会面大致就是这样结束的。但最奇怪的是后来发生的事。
I just told him, all right, well, we don't really have anything else to talk about. So I got up and walked out of the Bureau. And I could sense that he was behind me. But when I was standing at the elevator bank to go back down, he thrusts his business card into my hand.
我只是告诉他：“好吧，我们没什么可谈的了。”所以我起身走出局里。我能感觉到他在我身后。但当我站在电梯口准备下去时，他把名片塞进我手里。
And I didn't really understand, because obviously, I had this guy's contact info. There's no point in giving me a business card. And I looked down, and he's written the name of an Iraqi woman on his business card. And then he says to me in a hushed tone, he goes, look, if she gets in touch with you, make sure that you add her to your list.
我不明白为什么，因为显然我本来就有这个人的联系方式，给我名片毫无意义。我低头一看，他在名片上写了一个伊拉克女人的名字。然后他压低声音对我说：“听着，如果她联系你，确保把她加到你的名单里。”
It was literally 90 seconds earlier that he had been trying to scare me out of doing something. And now, he's asking me to help some Iraqi that he knew. And I looked at him, and his eyes glimmer, and he goes, don't worry. It's not like I slept with her or anything. But see if you can get her help or whatever.
就在90秒前，他还在试图吓唬我不准做这件事。现在，他却在请求我帮助一个他认识的伊拉克人。我看着他，他的眼神闪烁，他说：“别担心，我和她可没发生过什么。但看你能不能帮帮她或者之类的。”
That conversation and the sit-down with the State Department's Refugee Bureau happened in the winter of 2007. Kirk's conclusion was, well, that didn't work. His next move was more media pressure, some of which was happening on its own.
那次谈话和与国务院难民署的座谈发生在2007年冬天。柯克的结论是：好吧，这没用。他的下一步是通过媒体施压，其中一些施压已经在自发进行。
George Packer wrote in The New Yorker about Kirk's list and the Iraqis on it. And Kirk saw that any Iraqis mentioned in Packer's story started moving more quickly through the bureaucracy. So Kirk spent the next few months trying to get every journalist who asked for an interview to write about a different Iraqi on the list.
乔治·帕克在《纽约客》杂志上写了关于柯克的名单和名单上的伊拉克人的文章。柯克发现，任何出现在帕克文章里的伊拉克人，其处理速度都开始变快了。于是柯克接下来的几个月试图让每一个采访他的记者都写写名单上不同的伊拉克人。
He also talked with more government officials, and a lot of the conversations ended up being variations on the Saigon rooftop man meeting-- people in government who understood how bad the situation was but said to Kirk basically, no, I can't help you. But could you maybe help me?
他也与更多的政府官员谈过，许多谈话的结果都变成了“西贡屋顶男”那次会议的变体——政府里的人理解情况有多糟糕，但基本上对柯克说：“不，我不能帮你。但你能帮帮我吗？”
He contacted the congressman from his family's district in Illinois.
他联系了他家族在伊利诺伊州所在地区的国会议员。
Rep. Peter Roskam-- he's a friend of my dad's, because my dad had been a Republican in Illinois politics for some time.
彼得·罗斯坎众议员——他是我父亲的朋友，因为我父亲曾长期在伊利诺伊州的共和党政治圈工作。
Kirk says he asked him to cosponsor a piece of legislation that would help Iraqi interpreters, as well as Iraqi Christians who were under attack, and gay Iraqis, who were also being targeted all over the country.
柯克说他请求议员共同发起一项立法，帮助伊拉克翻译，以及受到攻击的伊拉克基督徒，还有当时在全国各地同样成为攻击目标的伊拉克同性恋群体。
And my congressman wouldn't sign on to it, because he didn't believe, out of principle, that gay people should receive any preferential treatment. And I think it was maybe a month afterwards, his chief of staff started referring names to my list. I have some of the emails here, if you want, but--
但我的国会议员不愿签署，因为从原则上讲，他不相信同性恋者应该受到任何优待。我想大概一个月后，他的幕僚长开始把名字发到我的名单上。如果你想看，我这里还有一些邮件，但是——
Yeah.
是的。
I'll skip the guy's name. "Kirk, so and so worked with me in Iraq and is now in danger from Iraqi militia organizations. Please add her to your list of Iraqis who worked with US forces. Thanks, period."
我跳过那个人的名字。“柯克，某某曾和我一起在伊拉克工作，现在受到伊拉克民兵组织的威胁。请把他加到你曾与美军合作的伊拉克人名单中。谢谢，句号。”
Just out of the blue without any reference to not sponsoring the legislation?
就这样毫无预兆，完全没提不支持那项立法的事？
Yeah. There's another one. This one was two minutes later. "Kirk, so and so and his wife so and so worked with me in Iraq in '03, '04, '05, and '06. They are now in danger in Iraq for the association with the Americans. Please add them to your list, period. Thanks, period."
是的。还有另一封。这个是两分钟后发来的。“柯克，某某和他的妻子曾在03、04、05和06年与我一起在伊拉克工作。他们现在因为与美国人的联系在伊拉克处于危险之中。请把他们加入你的名单，句号。谢谢，句号。”
Kirk realized that in Washington, people had all sorts of reasons not to help him with his list. One was straight up atmospherics, like I mentioned earlier. The list was bad news for the Bush administration, a clear indication that the war in Iraq was going terribly. And there was a bigger problem.
柯克意识到，在华盛顿，人们有各种理由不帮他处理这份名单。一个是纯粹的氛围原因，正如我刚才提到的。名单对布什政府来说是坏消息，清楚地表明伊拉克战争进展极其糟糕。还有一个更大的问题。
There's no point dancing around the fact that nobody in the State Department or Homeland Security wants their signatures to be on the next 9/11 hijacker's visa. And they've said this to me. I've gotten phone calls from people high up in State that have said, not everybody agrees with you that it's a good idea to be bringing over a lot of Muslims into the United States now. That's the gorilla in the room here is that we see these people as potential terrorists.
没必要回避这个事实：国务院或国土安全部的人没人希望自己的签名出现在下一个9/11劫机者的签证上。他们曾这样对我亲口说。我接到过国务院高层的电话，说：“不是每个人都同意你现在的想法，认为现在把大量穆斯林引入美国是个好主意。”这就是房间里的大象，我们把这些人视为潜在恐怖分子。
Even though you're talking about Iraqis who, because they worked for the US in Iraq, had been vetted there. Security procedures in order to allow them to work for USAID or [INAUDIBLE]--
尽管你说的那些伊拉克人，因为他们曾在伊拉克为美国工作，已经在那里经过了审查。为了让他们能在美国国际开发署或[听不清]工作，安全程序——
You can't ride in a Humvee with Marines without getting screened. The Iraqis that worked with me, they were all getting polygraph examinations. And I won't try to pull out this card, but I feel like I'm not so naive that-- as someone who spent a fair amount of time in Fallujah, I'm aware that there are bad people in the world. But the people I'm trying to help, they're actually running from terrorists.
你没法和海军陆战队一起坐悍马车而不经过审查。和我一起工作的伊拉克人，他们都经过了测谎仪测试。我不想摆出那种姿态，但我感觉我没那么天真——作为一个在费卢杰待了相当长一段时间的人，我意识到世界上有坏人。但我试图帮助的这些人，他们其实是在躲避恐怖分子。
One government official told Kirk he couldn't be seen with him, that he was toxic. Later, the man who suggested to Kirk that he should charter a boat and outrun the Coast Guard insisted on meeting with Kirk not in his office but in a sticky-floored bar in Washington at 2:00 in the afternoon.
一位政府官员告诉柯克，不能让别人看见他在一起，因为他被视为“有毒”的人。后来，那位建议柯克租船并甩掉海岸警卫队的人，坚持不在办公室见柯克，而是在下午2点华盛顿一家地板黏糊糊的酒吧里见面。
The most illuminating of these conversations was a bizarre encounter in Geneva, Switzerland. The UN had called a big meeting to talk about Iraqi refugees. When Kirk arrived, he got a call at his hotel from a US State Department official, a stranger.
这些谈话中最能说明问题的是在瑞士日内瓦的一次怪异邂逅。联合国召集了一次大型会议讨论伊拉克难民。柯克抵达时，在酒店接到了一个陌生人——美国国务院官员的电话。
And the man insisted that he had to talk to Kirk, and it had to be in person, and it had to be in secret. He told Kirk, there's a bridge near your hotel.
那个人坚持必须与柯克交谈，而且必须是当面，必须保密。他告诉柯克：“你酒店附近有一座桥。”
And I want you to go wait underneath that bridge. And I'm going to come up in a sedan with a license plate that ends in the number nine. And that's how you know it's me. And it was right around that time that that Russian dissident had been dosed with polonium. And I was like, are these my final moments?
“我要你去桥下等着。我会开一辆车牌末尾数字是9的轿车过来。那就是你认出我的方式。”就在那个时候，俄罗斯异见人士刚被钋毒害。我想，这会是我生命的最后时刻吗？
They were not his final moments. The man just drove him to a Chinese restaurant half an hour outside of Geneva in order to give him the names of two Iraqis with yet another cloak and dagger flourish.
那并不是他的最后时刻。那个人只是开车把他带到了离日内瓦半小时路程的一家中餐馆，再次以秘密特工的方式递给了他两个伊拉克人的名字。
He pulled out a small slip of paper from his pocket, and he put it on the lazy Susan between us and actually rotated the slip of paper to me. And I actually recognized the names, because they had just recently been referred to me by another State Department officer.
他从口袋里掏出一张小纸条，放在我们之间的转盘上，实际上是把它转给了我。我竟然认出了这两个名字，因为他们刚被另一位国务院官员推荐给我。
And I looked up, and I said, yeah. I already have them. They're already on the list. And I saw his shoulders relax. And he's just like, oh, thank God. Thank you. Thank you. I'm so glad they're going to be all right.
我抬起头说：“是的。我已经有了。他们已经在名单上了。”我看到他的肩膀放松下来了。他只是说：“噢，谢天谢地。谢谢你。谢谢。我真高兴他们会没事的。”
And when he said, now they're going to be OK--
当他说“现在他们会没事了”的时候——
Yeah, well--
是的，好吧——
How did you react to that in your mind? He was handing you this piece of paper as though, oh, now the process is going to happen. But the process wasn't happening. You hadn't been able to get a single Iraqi into the country yet.
你心里怎么反应？他把这张纸递给你，好像是“哦，现在流程会走了”。但流程根本没走。你还没能让哪怕一个伊拉克人进入美国。
No. I remember at one point, I was getting an email every 80 or 90 seconds from a family. And in some sort of overwrought case-- people were referring to me as the Schindler of the Iraqis and all this stuff just because I had a list, but I still had done nothing.
没有。我记得有一次，我每80或90秒就收到一个家庭的邮件。在某种夸张的情况下——人们称我为“伊拉克的辛德勒”之类，仅仅因为我有一份名单，但我实际上什么都没做成。
In some ways, I saw the list as a drain pipe that everything just sort of tumbled down into it, and people just chucked stuff into it and added names and this kind of thing. And I think in some way, it made a lot of people feel-- I think it's still does. It makes people feel like, oh, God. Here's this huge crisis. Here's this huge stain on the honor of our country, the abandonment of these people. But thank God there's this kid with a list.
从某种程度上讲，我把这份名单视为一个排水管，所有东西都往里面倒，人们只是把东西扔进去，增加名字等等。我觉得在某种程度上，这让很多人感觉——我觉得现在依然如此——这让人们觉得：“哦，天哪。这是一个巨大的危机。这是我们国家荣誉的一个巨大污点，是对这些人的抛弃。但谢天谢地，有这个拿着名单的孩子。”
Late spring 2007, Kirk realized there weren't enough journalists to write about everyone on the list. And he still hadn't gotten anyone out of Iraq and to safety, not even the ones who had been written about. They were just moving faster through a process that was opaque. No way to know for sure if they were two weeks away from an answer or two years.
2007年晚春，柯克意识到没有足够的记者去写名单上的每个人。他仍然没能让任何人离开伊拉克并确保安全，即使是那些被写过报道的人也是如此。他们只是在一条模糊的流程中前进得快一点点。没有办法确定离答案是两周还是两年。
Kirk was still in his aunt's basement, still basically broke. And the stress of what to do about the ever-increasing list was so relentless that he was getting headaches he couldn't shake for days in a row, grinding his teeth down. His whole existence was the list. He had no personal life.
柯克仍然住在阿姨家的地下室里，仍然几乎身无分文。处理不断增加的名单的压力如此巨大，以至于他连续几天头痛欲裂，牙齿磨得咯吱响。他的整个生活就是那份名单。他没有个人生活。
Every night, the laptop would be next to me in bed. And I'd wake up in the morning with more names to put in and type them into an Excel sheet.
每天晚上，笔记本电脑就在床边。早晨醒来，我又多了几个名字要输入Excel表格。
And then suddenly, there was movement. In the summer of 2007, Kirk and some lawyers officially formed an organization-- the List Project-- recruiting lawyers around the country to work with Iraqis on the list pro bono, helping them navigate the visa process.
然后突然间，有了进展。2007年夏天，柯克和一些律师正式组建了一个组织——“名单项目”（The List Project）——招募全国各地的律师免费为名单上的伊拉克人服务，帮助他们完成签证流程。
Kirk's friend, the Iraqi USAID colleague whose email had started everything, arrived in the US at the end of the summer with his wife. Kirk's parents in Illinois volunteered to take them in. And over the next year, Kirk worked with some senators, especially Senator Ted Kennedy, to get a law passed that would create a fast track for these Iraqis to get to the US.
柯克的那个伊拉克国际开发署同事（他的邮件开启了一切）在夏末带着妻子抵达了美国。柯克在伊利诺伊州的父母自愿收留了他们。接下来的那一年，柯克与一些参议员合作，尤其是泰德·肯尼迪参议员，通过了一项法律，为这些伊拉克人前往美国设立了快速通道。
Senator Kennedy was like a bulldozer when he got behind an issue. And he led this effort to create what was called the Refugee Crisis In Iraq Act. And what that did was create something called the Special Immigrant Visa for Iraqis, but also for Afghans who worked for us.
肯尼迪参议员一旦支持某个议题，就像推土机一样。他领导了这项努力，创建了所谓的《伊拉克难民危机法》。该法案设立了所谓的“伊拉克特殊移民签证”，同时也适用于曾为我们工作的阿富汗人。
And I'll never forget when it passed, because a few of us who had been involved with his office and were in the trenches on this, we were patched in. And we got to talk to Senator Kennedy on the floor of the Senate in the moments after the act passed.
我永远不会忘记它通过的那一刻，因为我们中几个一直参与他办公室工作并深陷其中的人，当时被连线了。我们在法案通过后的片刻，通过电话与参议院大厅里的肯尼迪参议员谈了话。
And it had all of this bipartisan support. Senator Brownback and Lugar and Senator Obama and Hillary Clinton were on it. And amazingly, it created 25,000 visa slots for Iraqis who worked for the Americans.
它得到了两党的广泛支持。布朗贝克、卢格参议员，还有奥巴马参议员和希拉里都在其中。令人惊讶的是，它为曾为美国工作的伊拉克人设立了25,000个签证名额。
Over the course of five years-- 5,000 a year, right?
五年内——每年5000个，对吧？
Exactly. But at that time when it passed, I had maybe-- I don't know-- 1,200 names on my list. And I just remembered, after I hung up with Kennedy, collapsing on the couch and truly feeling like it was over. Even if every one of my Iraqis took one of those visas-- the Iraqis on my list, I mean, there would still be tons left over for the others. And it was suddenly this-- it worked. We agitated, and now there's a new law.
没错。但在它通过的时候，我可能——不知道——名单上有1200个名字。我只记得在和肯尼迪通完话后，瘫在沙发上，真心觉得一切都结束了。即使我名单上的每个伊拉克人都用掉一个签证——我的意思是名单上的伊拉克人——仍然会有大量的名额留给其他人。突然间，这——成功了。我们进行了游说，现在有了新法律。
But members of the Bush administration had opposed the bill, and a year after it was enacted, only 172 Iraqis who'd worked with the US got in through the new, supposedly speedy Special Immigrant Visa program-- 172 out of a possible 5,000.
但布什政府的成员反对该法案，法案生效一年后，只有172名曾为美方工作的伊拉克人通过这个所谓的“快速”特殊移民签证项目进入了美国——25000个名额里只有172个。
That legislation was basically killed by Bush administration lawyers who found any kind of vague language in it to produce a very narrow, consular interpretation so that not many Iraqis who worked for us would be construed as eligible.
那项立法基本上被布什政府的律师扼杀了，他们从里面找各种模糊的措辞，给出了一个非常狭隘的领事解释，使得没几个曾为我们工作的伊拉克人被认为符合资格。
Under this narrow, consular interpretation, some Iraqis found out that they didn't qualify for a Special Immigrant Visa, because they had worked under a grant or a cooperative agreement rather than a contract, even though these were three different names for what amounted to the same thing. And for Iraqis who were eligible, there were delays, new choke points in the process.
在这种狭隘的领事解释下，一些伊拉克人发现他们没有资格获得特殊移民签证，因为他们工作属于“拨款”或“合作协议”项下，而不是合同项下，尽管这只是同一件事的三种不同说法。对于符合条件的伊拉克人，过程中充满了延误和新的阻碍点。
It's hard, because as we're speaking, I'm looking at a countdown now of a few months left when the five years are up. And it's going to expire. And out of the 25,000 slots, there's something like 18,000 that are still unused.
这很难，因为我们在说话时，我正盯着倒计时，五年期还剩几个月就要到了。它即将过期。25,000个名额里，有大约18,000个还没被用掉。
In March of this year, 19 members of Congress sent a letter to the Secretaries of State and Defense and the Department of Homeland Security saying that only 22% of the available Iraqi SIVs had been given out-- 5,500 visas out of a possible 25,000.
今年3月，19名国会议员致信国务卿、国防部长和国土安全部部长，称只有22%的伊拉克特殊移民签证被发放——25,000个名额中只发了5,500个。
Nancy Updike. She'll be back with Kirk Johnson in the second half of our show. Coming up, how you can provide two letters of recommendation, three certificates of merit, one work contract, an employment verification letter, and a federal contract number, plus four phone numbers and one email address for your old bosses, and that is still simply not enough proof of employment for the bureaucrats who are asking you for proof of employment before issuing the paperwork that will get you out of Iraq and save your life.
南希·厄普代克。她在我们节目的下半部分会回来与柯克·约翰逊一起探讨。接下来，你将了解到，如何提供两封推荐信、三份嘉奖证书、一份工作合同、一封工作证明信，以及一个联邦合同编号，再加上旧老板的四个电话号码和一个电子邮件地址，而这对于那些在你离开伊拉克并挽救生命前要求你提供就业证明的官僚来说，依然完全不够。
That is all in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
这一切都在一分钟后为您播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Taking Names," the story of Kirk Johnson's seven-year attempt to save the lives of Iraqis who worked with US forces during the war there.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《指名道姓》，讲述了柯克·约翰逊七年来试图拯救那些在伊拉克战争期间曾与美军合作的伊拉克人生命的尝试。
In this half of the show, to get a better sense of what is broken about our process for bringing these Iraqis into the United States, Nancy Updike looks at one guy. And though this guy seems to perfectly qualify for the Special Immigrant Visa program, the SIV program, which was created by law in 2008 specifically for Iraqis who worked with the US government in Iraq and whose lives are in danger as a result, this guy was not applying under that program, either because he didn't know that it existed or because he heard it was all jammed up, and going another way would be quicker or allow him to bring in more relatives. That is not unusual, Kirk Johnson says.
在这一半的节目中，为了更好地了解我们引入这些伊拉克人的流程究竟哪里出了问题，南希·厄普代克深入调查了一个案例。尽管这个人看起来完全符合特殊移民签证（SIV）项目——该项目是2008年通过法律专门为那些曾为美国政府工作且生命因此处于危险之中的伊拉克人设立的——但这个人并没有通过该项目申请，要么是因为他不知道它的存在，要么是因为他听说这个项目完全瘫痪了，走别的路可能会更快，或者能让他带进更多亲属。柯克·约翰逊说，这并不罕见。
Instead, he's applying through a different program-- something called the United States Refugee Admissions Program-- USRAP. This process involves the State Department and Homeland Security to make sure that we're not allowing terrorists into the country.
相反，他正在通过另一个项目申请——即所谓的“美国难民接收项目”（USRAP）。这个流程涉及国务院和国土安全部，以确保我们没有允许恐怖分子进入美国。
There's also an organization that does some overseas visa processing for the State Department called IOM. That's the International Organization for Migration. So I'm just saying all this to say you're going to be hearing a bunch of acronyms-- IOM and USRAP. That's basically what they are. It's these bureaucracies. Anyway, here's Nancy.
还有一个为国务院处理海外签证的组织叫IOM，即国际移民组织。我提这些是想说，你将会听到一堆缩写——IOM和USRAP。那基本上就是它们。它们就是这些官僚机构。总之，这里是南希。
A few months ago, Kirk sent me the draft of a book he's writing about all this. And the last chapter is about a case that's still going on now. That's the case I'm going to talk about. It was sent to the List Project a year ago in July of 2012.
几个月前，柯克寄给我一本他正在写的关于这一切的书的草稿。最后一章讲的是一个至今仍在进行的案例。这就是我要讲的案例。它是去年，即2012年7月被发送到“名单项目”的。
When Kirk got the email, he didn't know anything about it. It was just a zip file full of documents, and he started printing them and laying them all out.
柯克收到那封邮件时，对此一无所知。那只是一个装满文件的压缩包，他开始打印并将它们全部铺开。
I started with my kitchen table. When that filled up from all the pages laid out, I pulled some chairs up and used the chairs. And then I started running this paper trail along the floor.
我先是从厨房餐桌开始。当页面铺满桌子后，我拉了几把椅子过来，用椅子当桌子。然后我开始沿着地板布置这条纸质证据链。
You were trying to line everything up in chronological order?
你是在尝试把所有东西按时间顺序排列吗？
Exactly. But I'm basically looking at a dead man's attempt to get a visa.
正是。但我基本上是在看一个死人试图获得签证的尝试。
The documents are a back and forth between this one Iraqi man and the bureaucracies processing his refugee application. His first email goes like this. Kirk's translating it from Arabic.
这些文件是这个伊拉克男人与处理他难民申请的官僚机构之间的往来记录。他的第一封邮件是这样写的。柯克从阿拉伯语翻译过来。
"Greetings to those of you working in the immigration office. I ask your help in considering my request. I need a speedy solution to my situation, which is filled with persistent threats. People want to kill me because I worked for the US Army. Please help me come to America. Attached are some of the certificates and records of my work. Gratefully."
“向移民办公室的工作人员致敬。我请求你们帮助考虑我的申请。我需要尽快解决我的处境，这充满了持续的威胁。人们想杀我，因为我曾为美军工作。请帮我来美国。附件是一些我的工作证明和记录。感激不尽。”
And in the book, I call him Omar. But that's not his real name. So he applied on June 28. And their reply on October 9, 2011, was this. "Dear applicant, please be informed that your application is in process, but we still need a valid official email address for a supervisor or HR officer who can identify you and verify your employment and a copy of the contract between your company of employment and the US government. Please reply directly to this email, and do not change the subject line. Thank you."
在书里，我叫他奥马尔。但那不是他的真名。他在6月28日申请的。他们在2011年10月9日的回复是这样的：“亲爱的申请人，请知悉您的申请正在处理中，但我们仍然需要一位能够确认您的身份并验证您就业情况的监督员或人力资源官的有效官方电子邮件地址，以及一份您的雇佣公司与美国政府之间的合同副本。请直接回复此邮件，不要更改主题行。谢谢。”
In this exchange, Omar is providing six documents that corroborate his work for the United States, including contact information for American supervisors. He included copies of two contracts he'd had for projects overseen by Parsons, which is an American company. And there was a recommendation letter from the US Army. He'd worked for them as a forklift operator.
在这次往来中，奥马尔提供了六份证明他曾为美国工作的文件，包括美国监督员的联系信息。他附上了他曾参与的项目合同副本，这些项目由美国公司帕森斯（Parsons）负责。还有一封来自美军的推荐信。他曾作为叉车操作员为他们工作。
So here in front of me is a certificate of appreciation from the Department of the Army. "Your dedicated service to the US is appreciated and will not be forgotten." October 2009 to October 2010-- and then it's got the names of his supervisors.
这里我面前有一份来自陆军部的感谢状。“感谢您对美国的服务，我们不会忘记。”2009年10月至2010年10月——上面有他监督员的名字。
There were two more Army recommendation letters along with that one. And among the three, there were the names and signatures of six different US Army officers. There was also a letter from Parsons, the American company that oversaw the projects he worked for.
随信还有两封额外的陆军推荐信。这三封信上总共有六名不同美军军官的名字和签名。还有一封来自帕森斯的信，这家美国公司监管着他工作的项目。
"Parsons would be pleased to answer any questions concerning his employment. Contact can be made with the undersigned." And then they gave two phone numbers there.
“帕森斯很高兴回答有关他就业情况的任何问题。可以与签名者联系。”然后他们给出了两个电话号码。
This one here, this is one that also even says the exact long contract number that he worked under, the federal contract number. Again, at the bottom of this one, there's a Staff Sergeant signature, his DSN number, his phone number, and his Army email address.
这一份，甚至写着他工作的确切长期合同编号，即联邦合同编号。同样的，在这份文件的底部，有一个上士的签名、他的军方分机号、电话号码和陆军电子邮箱。
But in spite of all these documents and all this information, it seems clear from the emails that follow that the bureaucracies involved don't think that Omar has provided exactly the information they want-- a valid official email address for a supervisor-- even though they have four phone numbers for different supervisors and the official Army email address for one of Omar's supervisors. If they found that email address to be invalid for some reason, they don't make that clear to Omar.
但尽管有所有这些文件和信息，随后的邮件表明，相关的官僚机构似乎并不认为奥马尔提供了他们想要的确切信息——即“一位监督员的有效官方邮箱地址”——尽管他们已经有了四个不同监督员的电话号码，以及奥马尔其中一位监督员的陆军官方邮箱。如果他们因某种原因认为那个邮箱地址无效，他们并没有向奥马尔说明。
In the end of December-- actually the last day of the year, December 31, 2011-- at 9:46 AM, he sent a short note saying, "Peace and respect for everyone who works in your office. My brothers, I wonder if there's any news that you might share with me. What's the latest with my case? With great thanks, Omar."
12月底——实际上是那年的最后一天，2011年12月31日——上午9:46，他发了一条简短的便条，说：“和平与尊重给办公室里的每一位。兄弟们，不知道你们有没有什么消息可以分享给我。我的案件有什么进展吗？万分感谢，奥马尔。”
So the war has officially ended. The troops have fully pulled out. The base that he was working on doesn't exist anymore. Four days pass, and the State Department writes him back at 3:50 PM on January 4. It says, "Dear sir/ma'am, we have checked your case and found that it's in processing pending verifying your employment. Please note that once you are scheduled for an interview, you'll be contacted. Your patience does assist us in accelerating the process," which is a common phrase that I see all over the place, this strange notion that if they're just patient, things will speed up. It's not true.
战争已经正式结束。部队已经完全撤出。他工作的基地已经不存在了。四天过去了，国务院在1月4日下午3:50回复了他。信上说：“亲爱的先生/女士，我们已经检查了您的案件，发现其正在等待验证您的就业情况。请注意，一旦安排面试，我们会与您联系。您的耐心有助于我们加快进程。”这是一个我在到处都能看到的常用语，即那种奇怪的观念：如果他们有耐心，事情就会变快。那不是真的。
Not only was the process not on the verge of accelerating, Omar was trying to get out during a period when US officials admit that refugee processing for Iraqis had ground almost to a halt. It stayed slow for over a year. The US was beefing up its security screening procedures, because two Iraqis in Kentucky had been arrested and charged with sending money and weapons to al-Qaeda in Iraq.
不仅进展并没有加快的迹象，奥马尔试图离开时正处于美国官员承认伊拉克难民处理流程几乎陷入停滞的时期。这种情况持续了超过一年。美国正在加强安全审查程序，因为肯塔基州有两名伊拉克人被捕，并被控向伊拉克的基地组织输送资金和武器。
The two guys in Kentucky had never worked for the United States, like Omar had. They hadn't gotten into the US based on American military or civilian supervisors vouching for them in writing, the kind of letters Omar had. Omar was a different kind of case altogether. But he was Iraqi.
肯塔基州那两个人从未像奥马尔那样为美国工作过。他们没能根据美国军事或平民监督员的书面证明进入美国，也就是奥马尔拥有的那种证明信。奥马尔的情况完全不同。但他是个伊拉克人。
The next email that he wrote to the State Department-- this is February 16, 2012. I have all of these emails, but this one was the only one that was all in red. He had changed the font color.
他写给国务院的下一封邮件——这是2012年2月16日。我拥有所有这些邮件，但这一封是唯一全部用红色的。他换了字体颜色。
He says, "Peace and respect to you all. I'd like to explain some of the critical developments that have happened to me in Kirkuk. I feel that I'm in a very critical situation. My security isn't good, and I'm seeking your guidance. I fear for my life, the life of my family, and I'm asking for you to help me by transferring my case to a neighboring country. If you were able to transfer my file to Turkey, then my family and I will go to finish the visa process there. I await your speedy reply, God willing."
他说：“和平与尊重给你们大家。我想解释一下我在基尔库克遇到的一些严重事态发展。我觉得自己处于非常危险的境地。我的安全状况不好，正在寻求你们的指导。我为我的生命、家人的生命担忧，恳请你们通过将我的案件转往邻国来帮助我。如果你们能把我的档案转到土耳其，我和家人会去那里完成签证程序。静候你们的快速回复，愿上帝保佑。”
He's clearly trying to escalate the situation here and offering to flee to another country if--
他显然在这里试图升级事态，并提议逃往另一个国家，如果——
If that'll speed things up.
如果那能加快速度的话。
Right.
没错。
The next email back to Omar had a new paragraph that Kirk had seen in emails to other Iraqis and that would turn up again and again in Omar's case.
给奥马尔的下一封回复邮件中，包含了一段柯克在写给其他伊拉克人的邮件中看到的新段落，这段话在奥马尔的案件中一次又一次出现。
"Please note that you have to provide us with different contact info--" and then this is all in bold-- "official email address for a supervisor or HR officer who can identify you and verify your employment. Once we receive this, we will proceed with your case. Kind regards."
“请注意，您必须向我们提供不同的联系方式——”然后这部分全是粗体——“一位能够确认您的身份并验证您就业情况的监督员或人力资源官的官方电子邮箱地址。一旦我们收到，我们将继续处理您的案件。顺颂商祺。”
And this is where-- I had a wrestling match with the publisher, because in the initial submission of my book, I put the entire back and forth-- and it was 60 pages long-- because I wanted them to see how many times the exact same reply came back where they kept saying, please note that you have to provide us with different contact info.
这就是我与出版商进行过博弈的地方，因为在书的初稿中，我放入了所有往来记录——总共60页长——因为我希望他们看到完全相同的回复出现了多少次，他们不断重复说：“请注意，您必须提供不同的联系方式。”
Omar didn't write back saying, "I don't understand what's wrong with the contact information I already gave you. Please explain that to me so I know what to do." And the bureaucracy he's writing to is churning through about 500 new applicants a week in a system that operates like a customer service center for a credit card or phone company. Emails are answered in the order in which they're received by whichever employee is free to answer them, which means that one applicant might get emails from half a dozen different employees.
奥马尔没有回信问：“我不明白我提供的联系方式有什么问题。请向我解释，好让我知道该怎么做。”而他写信去的那个官僚机构，在一个像信用卡或电话公司客户服务中心那样运作的系统中，每周处理大约500名新申请人。邮件由谁有空回答就由谁按顺序回答，这意味着一个申请人可能会收到半打不同员工发来的邮件。
Finally, Omar asks a cousin in the United States to please track down one of his old supervisors and get new contact information. And then in the chronology of documents, there's a death threat against Omar. It's attached to his email. It's got a seal and a date on it.
最后，奥马尔请在美国的一位堂亲追踪他的一位旧上司并获取新的联系信息。然后，在文件时间轴中，出现了一个针对奥马尔的死亡威胁。它附在他的邮件里，上面有印章和日期。
From the Lightning Brigade of Ansar al-Sunna, which is-- we know them to be an al-Qaeda affiliate in Iraq. This is now several months after the war is over. Omar is not working for the Americans anymore. The Americans are gone.
来自“安萨尔伊斯兰军”（Lightning Brigade of Ansar al-Sunna），我们知道他们是伊拉克的一个基地组织分支。这时距离战争结束已经好几个月了。奥马尔不再为美国人工作了。美国人已经走了。
But this militia didn't care. An excerpt from the letter that I translated says, "To the atheist agent Omar, you are warned that if you do not accept the orders of the mujahideen by leaving your work with the American forces, your work as a spy-- we have warned you many times before, but you did not heed them. Nor did you return to the correct path. So we, the army of Ansar al-Sunna in Iraq, have decided to carry out the punishment of execution if you do not leave your work."
但这支民兵不在乎。我翻译的信件摘录写着：“给无神论者代理人奥马尔，警告你，如果你不听从圣战者的命令停止与美军的合作，继续做你的间谍工作——我们警告过你多次，但你没理会。也没回归正途。所以，伊拉克的安萨尔伊斯兰军决定，如果你不停止工作，就执行死刑处罚。”
So he's caught, and there's two bureaucracies. There's a bureaucracy of a militant organization that's sending him their outdated threat email, which is saying, you have to leave your job, that he's already out of, or we're going to kill you. And then there's also this bureaucracy saying, you have to send us more information that he's already sent them.
所以他被困住了，这中间有两个官僚机构。有一个激进组织官僚机构，正在发过时的死亡威胁邮件，说“你必须辞职，否则我们会杀了你”（而他实际上已经离职了）。还有另一个官僚机构，说“你必须给我们发更多信息”（而他已经发过了）。
Our bureaucracy doesn't know if he worked for us. And their bureaucracy is certain that he did, but they don't realize that we're gone.
我们的官僚机构不知道他是否为我们工作过。而他们的官僚机构确信他工作过，但他们没意识到美国人已经撤走了。
We showed this threat letter to three Iraqi translators with experience reading death threats from different Iraqi militias. And they disagreed about its authenticity. One translator pointed out that the death threat had the same kinds of grammatical errors that Omar's emails and later his brother's emails did, so we can't be sure it's real.
我们将这封威胁信给三位有处理不同伊拉克民兵死亡威胁经验的伊拉克翻译看。他们对信件的真实性意见不一。一位翻译指出，这封死亡威胁和奥马尔后来邮件中的语法错误类型相同，所以我们不能确定它是真的。
Whether or not it was real, Omar at this point fled to Turkey with the idea of finding an apartment and a job and then bringing his family. But he couldn't get permission to work in Turkey, so he went back to Iraq and started moving his family from house to house, hiding.
不管真假，奥马尔此时逃往土耳其，想先找公寓和工作，然后再接家人。但他无法在土耳其获得工作许可，所以他回到了伊拉克，开始带着家人从一个房子搬到另一个房子，藏匿起来。
Finally, his cousin in America did track down new contact information for one of his American bosses, a guy from Parsons. And on April 5, nine months after Omar's first email, the US State Department contacted Omar's former boss.
最后，他在美国的堂亲确实找到了他的一位美国老板的新联系信息，那个人来自帕森斯公司。4月5日，即奥马尔第一封邮件发出九个月后，美国国务院联系了奥马尔的前老板。
Exactly 25 minutes later, at 11:47 AM, Omar's old boss at Parsons says, "Yes, I remember him to the best of my knowledge, and attached is further reference. I hope this is sufficient." And he included this letter, where he said, "To whom it may concern, it's my pleasure to provide reference for Omar. His performance working as a maintenance and laborer for the Parsons-Iraq joint venture was outstanding. I knew Omar for more than two years of my capacity as a materials logistics manager, around May 2004 to August 10 of 2006. He was an extremely positive asset as to our endeavors while in Iraq. If I can be of any further assistance or provide you with any further information, please do not hesitate to contact me."
仅仅25分钟后，上午11:47，奥马尔在帕森斯的老老板说：“是的，我尽我所能记得他，附件是进一步证明。希望这些足够了。”他还附上了这封信，上面写着：“致相关方，很高兴为奥马尔提供推荐。他作为帕森斯-伊拉克合资企业的维护和劳工表现极为出色。我以材料物流经理的身份认识奥马尔两年多，大约是2004年5月到2006年8月10日。他在伊拉克期间是我们努力的一个极其积极的资产。如果我能提供进一步帮助或信息，请务必联系我。”
He's got his office number, cellphone, email address, and it's on official Parsons letterhead. When I saw this, this seems like-- I was relieved when I saw this, because until this point, when I first looked at this case, I didn't know how the story ended. I just thought that this was another typical case of the process dragging on for somebody, and maybe they needed our help to nudge it forward.
他有他的办公室电话、手机、邮箱地址，而且是在帕森斯正式的信笺上。当我看到这个时，我松了一口气，因为在这之前，当我第一次看这个案子时，我不知道故事如何结尾。我只觉得这是流程拖延的又一个典型案例，也许他们需要我们的帮助来推动一下。
So I was getting anxious until I saw this letter. And I was like, this is great. Everything's on official letterhead. It's directly to people that I know in the State Department that are all cc'ed on this email.
所以我很焦虑，直到看到这封信。我说，太好了。所有东西都在正式信笺上。这直接发给了我认识的、都在此邮件抄送名单里的国务院官员。
Omar got an email back saying, "We got the contact information you sent, and we'll be in touch." Omar wrote back immediately.
奥马尔收到回信说：“我们收到了您发送的联系信息，会再联系您。”奥马尔立即回信。
Kind of a hopeful but still desperate email. He says, "Peace and greetings, my brothers. Now that you have the official email address, I'm wondering whether my file might be transferred to Jordan. Are there any steps left that I need to do? I need resolution. Time is passing here. I don't own anything. I don't work. I'm moving from house to house, from here to there. I beg you to find a solution. Please call me."
这是一种充满希望但依然绝望的邮件。他说：“和平与问候，我的兄弟们。现在你们有了官方邮箱地址，我想知道我的档案是否可以转到约旦？还有什么步骤我需要完成吗？我需要解决。时间在流逝。我一无所有。我不工作。我从一个房子搬到另一个房子，居无定所。我恳求你们找到解决方案。请给我打电话。”
Next email-- this is dated April 17. This is less than 10 days after they told him that they had received the employment letter. On April 17, 1:41 PM, they sent Omar this letter. "Dear sir, thank you for your email. We have checked your case and found that it's in processing your employment verification." I'm reading this exactly as it's written.
下一封邮件——日期是4月17日。这距离他们告诉他收到就业信还不到10天。在4月17日下午1:41，他们发给奥马尔这封信：“亲爱的先生，感谢您的邮件。我们检查了您的案件，发现其正在处理您的就业验证。”我读的是它上面写的原话。
"Please understand that the process is lengthy and might need a long period of time. Your patience does assist us in accelerating the process. Since your employment has been verified yet, you aren't advised to transfer your case to Jordan. Kind regards."
“请理解，这个过程很冗长，可能需要很长时间。您的耐心有助于我们加快进程。由于您的就业还没有验证成功，不建议您将案件转移到约旦。顺颂商祺。”
If you, as an American, can tell me what that means-- those sentences together-- I'd love to know. But it's like asking Siri to save your life or something. You're talking to a robot that seems incapable of learning, much less giving you a visa.
如果你作为一个美国人能告诉我那是什么意思——那些句子连在一起——我洗耳恭听。但这就像让Siri来救你的命一样。你在和一个似乎没有学习能力的机器人说话，更别提给你签证了。
As April turned into May, he kept sending them emails telling them, "I'm in real danger here. I've received another new death threat. I carry the letter with me, which I can send to you or bring with me when you interview me. I'm waiting for your call." And then he puts, like, six exclamation marks at the end of that.
进入5月，他一直发邮件告诉他们：“我真的处于危险之中。我又收到了一个新的死亡威胁。我随身带着那封信，可以发给你们，或者面试时带去。我在等你们的电话。”然后，他在那句话结尾加了六个感叹号。
Again, the death threat was included in the documents. And our translator raised the same questions about this one as with the earlier one.
同样，死亡威胁包含在文件中。我们的翻译对这一封也提出了和之前那一封同样的问题。
Seven weeks after that, after the State Department's employment verification unit received the verification letter from his boss, Omar again receives an email that says-- this is on May 22, 2012.
那之后七周，在国务院就业验证部门收到他老板的验证信之后，奥马尔再次收到一封信——时间是2012年5月22日。
"Dear sir or madam, please note that we are unable to verify your employment. Kindly provide us with different contact info, official email address for a supervisor or HR officer who can identify you and verify your employment. Please reply to this email, and do not change the subject line. Kind regards."
“亲爱的先生或女士，请注意，我们无法验证您的就业情况。请友好地向我们提供不同的联系方式、能够确认您的身份并验证您就业情况的监督员或人力资源官的官方电子邮箱地址。请回复此邮件，不要更改主题行。顺颂商祺。”
It's like they've gone back to the beginning.
就像他们又回到了起点。
Right. This is the last round of correspondence, because less than two weeks later, on June 9, Omar gets a phone call. His wife said that he took the call in the other room, spoke for a couple minutes, and then came back in. They were still sitting around the kitchen table. He told his wife that he needed to step outside but that he was going to come back soon.
没错。这是最后一轮通信，因为不到两周后，6月9日，奥马尔接到了一个电话。他的妻子说，他去另一个房间接了电话，说了几分钟，然后回来。他们当时还围在厨房餐桌旁。他告诉妻子他需要出去一下，但很快会回来。
Omar's decapitated body was found later that night. That's what Omar's widow told the List Project. His death certificate is the next one in the chronology of documents.
奥马尔被斩首的尸体当晚晚些时候被发现。这就是奥马尔的遗孀告诉“名单项目”的。他的死亡证明是文件时间轴中的下一项。
It's hard to read through this correspondence and not have questions at the end. What happened here? Is this systemic incompetence? Is this one anomalous tragic screw up? Is it part of some deliberate attempt to stall Iraqi applicants? The State Department doesn't comment on specific cases, but I talked to an official in the State Department's Refugee Bureau and asked whether they think the current process is functioning fine or has significant problems.
很难读完这些通信而最后没有疑问。这里发生了什么？这是系统性的无能吗？这是一起反常的悲惨失误吗？这是某种拖延伊拉克申请人的蓄意尝试的一部分吗？国务院不对具体案件发表评论，但我与国务院难民署的一位官员谈过，问他们是否认为当前的流程运行正常还是存在重大问题。
The official didn't want to be named but said, quote, "I don't think the processing part of this is broken at all. I think there are unfortunate cases where it doesn't work. But looking at it as a whole, I think it's not something we can say is broken, because I've seen too many successes. More than 90,000 Iraqis have been able to come to the US through the SIV and refugee programs and start new lives," unquote.
那位官员不愿具名，但说：“我不认为处理部分出了问题。我认为存在不幸的案例，流程没有起效。但从整体来看，我不认为可以说它出了问题，因为我见过太多成功的案例。超过90,000名伊拉克人通过特殊移民签证和难民项目来到美国，开始了新生活。”
That 90,000 is such a big number because it's counting all Iraqis who have come to America since 2007. Iraqis who worked with the US are a small subset of that number, around 17,000.
那90,000是个很大的数字，因为它计算的是2007年以来所有来到美国的伊拉克人。曾为美国工作的伊拉克人只是其中的一小部分，大约17,000人。
Another State Department official said, quote, "There is no policy to slow down the refugee or SIV process. Quite the opposite. Overall processing times have improved significantly in the past year," unquote.
另一位国务院官员说：“没有任何减缓难民或特殊移民签证处理流程的政策。恰恰相反。过去一年中，总体处理时间已显著改善。”
But the government won't disclose how many Iraqis who worked with the US, who qualify for fast track processing, have applied to get in or how long they've been waiting. Kirk's list alone has 1,500 people on it, and his organization is just one of several that does this work.
但政府不愿披露有多少曾为美方工作、符合快速通道处理条件的伊拉克人申请了签证，或者他们已经等了多久。仅柯克的名单上就有1,500人，而他的组织只是从事这项工作的几个组织之一。
As the Iraq War was ending, Kirk met with White House officials to push a plan that would deal all at once with all of the Iraqis who had worked for the US and wanted to come here. The plan was that President Obama could issue an executive order and put the Iraqis on airplanes and fly them to a secure military base outside the continental United States-- Guam, for instance.
随着伊拉克战争即将结束，柯克与白宫官员会面，推进一个计划，以一次性解决所有曾为美方工作并希望来美的伊拉克人的问题。该计划是，奥巴马总统可以发布行政命令，把伊拉克人送上飞机，飞往美国大陆之外的安全军事基地——比如关岛。
At the base, they could be screened as thoroughly as they needed to be to keep the US safe. And at the same time, they would be safe. This was not a new idea. We'd done it before several times in similar situations.
在基地，他们可以像需要的那样彻底进行审查，以确保美国的安全。同时，他们也会安全。这不是一个新主意。我们在类似情况下以前做过好几次。
It's what we call the Guam Option. And we flew 7,000 Iraqis out of northern Iraq in '96. In two weeks, we flew 7,000 out directly to Guam. And the average processing time there was 90 days. And those Iraqis are all Americans now.
这就是我们所说的“关岛选项”。我们在96年把7,000名伊拉克人从伊拉克北部撤出。在两周内，我们直接用飞机把7,000人运到了关岛。那里的平均处理时间是90天。那些伊拉克人现在都是美国人了。
In '99, we flew 12,000 Kosovar Albanians directly to Fort Dix. When we did do the evacuation of the boat people from Vietnam, we used Guam and these other bases. Guam can hold something like 24,000 refugees at any point in time.
99年，我们把12,000名科索沃阿尔巴尼亚人直接运到了迪克斯堡。当我们要撤离越南船民时，我们用了关岛和这些其他基地。关岛在任何时候都可以容纳大约24,000名难民。
There were tools on the table that could have stopped all of this. It just can't happen without the presidential order, because it requires the military with all of its power to do the initial bit of heavy lifting, to save the lives of these high-priority refugees and bring them to a secure location so that State and Homeland Security and others can do the screening.
桌面上有很多工具本可以阻止这一切。只是没有总统令就无法实现，因为它需要拥有全部权力的军方来承担最初的重任，拯救这些高优先级难民的生命，把他们带到安全地点，这样国务院、国土安全部和其他部门才能进行审查。
I went and spoke before Congress and spoke specifically on this. We got a bill passed that instructed the White House and their agencies to produce planning and to start contingency planning. And at every step of the way, they just ignored all of this and said, they're going to be fine. These Iraqis, like Omar, are going to be fine. We're not going to do a Guam Option.
我曾去国会发言，专门谈到这一点。我们通过了一项法案，指示白宫及其机构制定计划并开始应急规划。但在每一个环节，他们只是忽略了一切，说：“他们会没事的。”像奥马尔这样的伊拉克人会没事的。我们不会执行“关岛选项”。
And I used to be able to go to the White House and push this. And I can't now. They don't let me anymore. But the thing that's exasperating about all this is it didn't need to happen. And it's not that I'm some super rosy-eyed kid that doesn't understand anymore what other options are on the table. There are tools.
我以前还能去白宫推动这件事。现在不能了。他们不再让我去了。但这一切令人愤慨的是，它本来没必要发生。并不是说我是一个不再明白桌面上还有什么选项的、天真得过头的孩子。工具是有的。
And so even when the Brits left, they did an airlift. They put their Iraqi employees directly on planes and flew them to Oxfordshire to an RAF base there. Australians airlifted out all of their Iraqis. Denmark airlifted out all of their Iraqis in a single night, Poland the same.
甚至英国人撤军时，他们也进行了空运。他们把伊拉克雇员直接送上飞机，飞往那里的英国皇家空军基地。澳大利亚人空运了他们所有的伊拉克雇员。丹麦人一夜之间空运了所有伊拉克雇员，波兰也是一样。
Kirk says the last time he was at the White House was November 2011.
柯克说他最后一次去白宫是在2011年11月。
The thing that I remember from that meeting was-- there were List Project lawyers there as well. An NSC-- a National Security Council-- official walked up to one of our lawyers. And they said to us, we understand that the Iraqis on your list have a subjective fear. But there's no objective basis for them to be afraid anymore. And Omar died a few months later. It still sits in me like a splinter, because that's coming from the White House.
我从那次会面中记得的是——当时也有“名单项目”的律师在场。一位国家安全委员会官员走到我们的一位律师面前。他们对我们说：“我们明白你们名单上的伊拉克人有主观恐惧。但他们已经没有客观依据去害怕了。”而奥马尔几个月后就死了。这仍然像刺一样扎在我心里，因为那是来自白宫的话。
For the United States, the Iraq War ended a long time ago. Inside Iraq, no one has forgotten who they hated or who hated them. Scores are still being settled all over the country. Hundreds of people are dying every month in bombings and shootings. And militants still target Iraqis who worked for the US.
对于美国来说，伊拉克战争很久以前就结束了。在伊拉克境内，没有人忘记谁恨他们，或者谁憎恨谁。全国各地的恩怨仍在清算。每月都有数百人在爆炸和枪击中死去。武装分子依然把曾为美国工作的伊拉克人作为目标。
When I interviewed Kirk, it was two and a half weeks after the Boston Marathon bombing. He had been working for months with some senators, including Senator John McCain, trying to extend the Special Immigrant Visa program for Iraqis so it won't expire this year. And I asked him if he was worried that the bombers being Muslim would scuttle the legislation.
我采访柯克时，距离波士顿马拉松爆炸案已经过去了两周半。他已经与包括约翰·麦凯恩在内的一些参议员合作了数月，试图延长伊拉克人的特殊移民签证项目，以免其今年过期。我问他是否担心波士顿爆炸案的凶手是穆斯林会搅黄立法。
Yeah. I don't know. It pisses me off. I live in Boston. I walk down that street all the time.
是的。我不知道。这让我很火大。我住在波士顿。我经常走那条街。
But they weren't Iraqis. But it's like the same false choice that is always put in front of me. The people on my list are not these guys. And I'm convinced. I'm certain about it. So are the thousands of Marines and soldiers and aid workers whose names are all attached to the list.
但他们不是伊拉克人。但这就像总是摆在我面前的那个虚假选择。我名单上的人不是那些家伙。我确信这一点。名单上挂着名字的成千上万的海军陆战队员、士兵和援助人员也都确信。
And I'm not stupid. I'm not making any excuses for terrorists or anything. But can't we at least we have one shade of nuance in understanding that not every Muslim is trying to kill us, and that for years, for a decade, people risked their lives to try to help us?
而且我并不傻。我没为恐怖分子找借口或什么的。但我们难道不能在理解上有一点细微差别吗？难道不能承认不是每个穆斯林都想杀我们，而且多年来、十年来，人们冒着生命危险试图帮助我们？
That's all I'm asking. It's just one grain. I'm not asking people to become experts in the difference between Sunni and Shia Islam. I'm not trying to have them learn Arabic or anything. Just give me that. Just recognize that not all of these people are bad, lethal people.
这就是我所要求的。只是这一点点认知。我没要求人们成为逊尼派和什叶派伊斯兰教区别的专家。我没试着让他们学习阿拉伯语什么的。只要给我这一点。只要承认不是所有这些人都是坏人、致命的人。
I'm just really tired. And I don't say that in like a woe is me thing. I just feel like I've thrown everything I can against this. And I'm out of ideas. I really don't know what else there is to do.
我只是真的很累。我这并不是在装可怜。我只是觉得我已经竭尽所能去抗争了。我没主意了。我真的不知道还能做什么。
After seven years, Kirk says he might be ready to declare defeat. He's helped get about 1,500 Iraqis out. But another 1,500 are still on the list, waiting. And others died before they could make it out.
七年过去了，柯克说他也许准备宣布失败了。他帮助大约1,500名伊拉克人离开了。但名单上还有另外1,500人在等待。其他人则在逃出来之前就死了。
Kirk says we're failing to do what we set out to do. Now he wants to do something else with his life. He's tired of being a scold.
柯克说我们未能完成我们的既定目标。现在他想把人生花在别处。他厌倦了当一个唠叨的人。
We're very rapidly entering the point in history that it's impolite to talk about the war, that if I bring it up at a dinner party or something, I get awkward, like, oh, you're still talking about that?
我们正在迅速进入一个谈论这场战争会被视为“不礼貌”的历史阶段，如果我在晚宴或其他场合提起它，我会感到尴尬，比如：“哦，你还在说那个？”
That's awkward.
那确实尴尬。
Yeah. Before long, I'll be the guy in a wheelchair shouting about the abandonment of our Iraqi allies at the 4th of July parade in West Chicago in 2070 or something.
是的。很快，我就会成为那个在2070年西芝加哥国庆游行上，坐在轮椅上大喊我们抛弃伊拉克盟友的怪老头了。
Kirk Johnson, speaking with Nancy Updike. You can read the entire correspondence between Omar and the bureaucrats. And I recommend this. It is even more staggering than we can communicate here over the radio. We created a timeline with all the documents online at ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames-- again, ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames.
柯克·约翰逊，与南希·厄普代克对话。你可以阅读奥马尔与官僚之间的全部往来邮件。我推荐大家去读。它比我们在电台上传达的更加惊人。我们在线上制作了一个包含所有文件的时间轴：ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames ——再说一遍，ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames。
We did show the State Department and the International Organization for Migration-- the IOM-- the emails and the correspondence that seemed to have come from their organizations. They would not confirm that they had sent out these particular emails. But they did confirm that these emails were characteristic of the types of emails they do send.
我们确实向国务院和国际移民组织（IOM）展示了那些似乎来自他们的邮件和往来记录。他们没有确认他们发送过这些特定邮件。但他们确认，这些邮件确实符合他们通常发送的邮件类型。
This week, by the way, the Senate voted to extend and improve the Special Immigrant Visa programs in Iraq and Afghanistan, which are due to expire next year. That is the good news.
顺便说一句，本周，参议院投票通过延长并改进伊拉克和阿富汗的特殊移民签证项目，这些项目定于明年过期。这是好消息。
The bad news is the Senate did this as one small section of their comprehensive immigration reform bill, which who knows what will survive with that, if anything, once the House of Representatives takes it up.
坏消息是参议院将此作为其全面移民改革法案的一小部分，如果众议院确实要讨论这个法案，谁知道里面会有什么存活下来。
Kirk Johnson's memoir, To Be a Friend is Fatal, The Fight to Save the Iraqis America Left Behind , will be out this September.
柯克·约翰逊的回忆录《做朋友是致命的：拯救被美国遗留的伊拉克人的战斗》，将于今年9月出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollack, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Phia Bennin.
好了，我们的节目今天由米基·米克制作，与亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克合作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自菲亚·本宁。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Research by Michelle Harris.
赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格德斯。研究员是米歇尔·哈里斯。
Our special interactive timeline of Omar documents was produced by Zach Wise and Miki Meek. Again, visit our website, ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames.
我们关于奥马尔文件的特别交互式时间轴由扎克·怀斯和米基·米克制作。再一次，访问我们的网站：ThisAmericanLife.org/TakingNames。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who visited York City recently. And I don't know, it seems like he had a really weird visit to the Statue of Liberty.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们节目由老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生监管，他最近去了纽约市。我不知道，他去自由女神像的访问似乎非常奇怪。
Don't worry, it's not like I slept with her anything.
别担心，我和她可没发生过什么。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "RED TAPE" BY THE NEVERBEENS]
[音乐播放 - The Neverbeen演唱的《红头文件》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。